March 4th 2018 4 pm it's just another
day for the residents of Salisbury
England all throughout the city people
are heading home from work everything
looks and feels exactly as it always has
a woman and her daughter step onto the
streets making their way through the
center of the city but then just as they
reach a bus stop that they've passed
hundreds of times the daughter notices
something strange right ahead on the
public bus bench lie a man and a woman
completely unconscious the woman's eyes
are wide open and completely white
there's white foam coming out of her
mouth something is seriously wrong
24 hours earlier a 66 year old Russian
man Sergey skripal and his daughter
Yulia arrive in London from Russia
Sergey has spent years as a spy for
Russia in the UK what the Russians
didn't know was that he was also passing
information to MI6 the UK's version of
the CIA
when Russia eventually figured it out he
was caught and sentenced to 13 years in
prison luckily for Sergey he was part of
a prisoner swap in 2010 soon after he
was released he moved to the UK
permanently Sergey believed his betrayal
was in the past there was no way anyone
would still have a vendetta years after
he was sent to prison anyways right
unfortunately for him he underestimated
how long Russia could hold a grudge what
he had done was the ultimate betrayal
against Mother Russia they just couldn't
let it go as Sergey and Yulia arrived
back in London undercover assassins were
waiting for them these assassins were a
part of Russia's Infamous Gru the gru as
Russia's Military Intelligence they have
their own special forces units they
answered directly to Russia's military
command and they were even more ruthless
than the KGB ever was
Sergey and Julio went out for lunch
around 2PM they had a few drinks in the
city center and everything seemed normal
but then suddenly everything went wrong
the two found their muscles paralyzed as
they were desperately crying for help
suffocating from the inside you see
these two had just been poisoned and no
it wasn't in their food or drinks the
poison is known as novichok and it was
sprayed on the front door handle of
sergey's home that is all it took to
incapacitate the father and daughter
leading them to crawl onto a bus bench
waiting to die when luckily an Army
Nurse and her daughter found them an
ambulance was called as Sergey and Yulia
were rushed to the hospital miraculously
both survived after a long stay in the
hospital
the Gru's plan may have failed but the
message was clear no matter where you
run no matter where you hide if the
Russian government wants you they will
get to you these agents didn't try to
hide their face or try to assassinate
Sergey in secret they didn't care about
CCTV cameras or being seen they were
here to send a message they wanted
everyone to know who they were and what
they had done
for decades the gru has been the Russian
government's number one choice for doing
his Dirty Work they're the guys poon
sentence when he wants to make a
statement when he wants to create fear
in his enemies and they are experts at
what they do this is the gru Russia's
most feared assassins
foreign
Russia's Gru members are chosen for
their skills and abilities and one skill
that can make you a lot of money right
now is data science where the average
data scientist makes around 121 000 a
year but it can go up a lot more than
that that's where data Camp comes in
data Camp is an online learning platform
that teaches data science and data
skills to over 350 000 students around
the world all online and at their own
pace covering everything from non-coding
Essentials that everyone should know to
full-blown data science and machine
learning there are literally
democratizing data skills for everyone
which is a super valuable skill right
now the average data scientist makes 121
000 a year but it can go up a lot more
data Camp has over 350 courses for
people at every skill level to become
more data fluent and the courses are
designed by top experts in the field I
really like their skill tracks which
provide you with a collection of courses
to build up a specific skill for total
newbies I'd recommend the data literacy
fundamental skill track which teaches
you how to understand all types of data
through Hands-On exercises and if you're
not sure where the starts you can take
one of datacam's free assessments to get
personalized learning recommendations
plus datacam doesn't require any
software you can do everything right
inside your browser unlock new career
opportunities and become data fluent
today by using my link below and
checking out the first chapter of any
data Camp course for free pause the
video and click the link below to get
started now thanks to datacam for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
the gru is the oldest of all of Russia's
intelligence agencies back when Joseph
Stalin was in power he needed a group of
people to spy on the Nazis and the gru
was his answer unlike other Russian
agencies the gru recruits were some of
the toughest in the world they were
loyal to the deaf and they would stop
nowhere to fulfill their orders one
write a passage for new recruits was
watching a video of an officer who
betrayed Russia get fed into a
crematorium alive when the KGB collapsed
in 1991 the gru temporarily took its
place unlike the Agents of the KGB Gru
operatives would never dream of going up
against Russia's leadership and that's
exactly how the government liked it when
the FSB was finally created to take the
kgb's place the competition was intense
both agencies wanted to be the best they
wanted to be the president's pick to do
that they have to show how creative they
were and how proactive they were in
fixing the Russian government's problems
this led to the two agencies carrying
out some of the riskiest and most
ruthless operations in history all to
tried to win the president's favor
today the competition is still going
strong
this is Alexander Livi ninka a longtime
Russian FSB agent an author a Putin
critic and the man who solved his own
murder
in the year 2000 Alexander fled to the
UK after becoming a little too critical
of Vladimir Putin he was scared of being
arrested or killed and to him England
seemed a safe of a bet as any he never
imagined what would be waiting for him
you see Alexander just couldn't let go
of his life as a spy so in exchange for
his safety he started doing some work
for MI6 his background meant that he
could get into circles other agents
couldn't by 2006 he was necked deep in
the case against the Russian mafia with
an old friend and former spy Andre
lugovy
on November 1st 2006 the two met for tea
at a London hotel they were joined by
two other Russian men soon after the
meeting ended Alexander started feeling
sick he spent the night vomiting and
three days later he went to a nearby
hospital something was very wrong a few
weeks later he died
the cause of death polonium poisoning
polonium is one of the most toxic
substances known to man up to a trillion
times stronger than Cyanide and is
radioactive looking back it was probably
the tea that he drank at that meeting
once the polonium entered his
bloodstream all of Alexander's major
organs were under attack by the time he
got to the hospital it was already too
late
Alexander cooperated with the police
right up until the end with this help
they were able to figure out that the
two men that joined him for tea were
Russian Gru agents apparently Moscow had
never gotten over Alexander's betrayal
and he wasn't the only one Alexander was
just one name on a long list of names
targeted by a special Department of the
gru known only as unit 29155
unit 29155 is in charge of all of the
Gru's assassinations and sabotage
attempts in 2020 another unit 29155
operation was uncovered this time the
agents offer Taliban members huge
bounties for every American Soldier they
killed 20 American soldiers were killed
the year before at least some of the men
responsible may have received money in
exchange for their attacks
but the gru aren't just bloodthirsty
assassins going after traitors this is
fancy bear a group of elite hackers and
coders their job the online sabotage of
any pro-american or anti-russian groups
or companies and they have some pretty
creative ways of doing it in 2015 they
took over France's national TV network
but instead of announcing it was them
they made it look like it was a group of
hackers for Isis they called themselves
a Cypher caliphates they kept the 12
news channels hostage for over 3 hours
they even had the net Worth's Facebook
and Twitter pages and when the world
anti-doping agency wanted to ban Russia
from using performance enhancing drugs
while fancy bear got into their user
database and sent thousands of phishing
emails trying to gather information they
can lead to the public do you have any
doubt that the Russian government was
behind the intrusions in the DNC and the
D Triple C systems and the subsequent
leaks of that information no no doubt
even though they don't openly claim to
be a part of the gru everyone know knows
who they answered to and they were
always there when the agency needs them
[Music]
it was May 1968's the peak of the
Vietnam War America was necked deep in
its military operations but the
Americans didn't know was right around
the time the fighting in Vietnam reaches
Peak nine young Russian men were
sneaking onto a secret U.S Air Base in
Cambodia America had just started
producing a brand new attack helicopter
called the Super Cobra Russia's
helicopter designs were falling behind
and they needed a working American
Helicopter to reverse engineer so these
nine men went in killed 15 American
soldiers hijacked a helicopter and
destroyed all the others at the base
the US government kept the raid a secret
for years it was too big of an
embarrassment while those nine men were
ordinary soldiers they were a part of
Russia's most elite special forces the
Spetsnaz which is the gruyu special
forces and the equivalent to the
American Navy Seals are the best of the
best of the Russian military they train
under live fire often get stabbed in
training and have to pass some of the
toughest entry tests in the world
they're the tip of the Russian military
Spear and right now that tip of the
spirit is in Ukraine
Ukraine is probably the most important
battle in the history of modern day
Russia it's a war to prove if Russia is
still a superpower and if it shouldn't
be underestimated which is why it's not
surprising that Vladimir Putin has sent
in everyone he could think of into
Ukraine to tit the scales in his favor
the infamous Wagner group was in Ukraine
long before The Invasion started of
course the Russian military has sent in
his troops and to back all of these
groups up there's the gru sent into
Ukraine to make sure Putin doesn't lose
they're there to operate in the gray
area between politics intelligence
propaganda and combats and if history is
anything to go by these guys are the
ones to fear most
foreign